but here's some of my fears when I was
thinking about it you know marriage
scares me you know because you got to
stay there you know it's like being in
an elevator and the elevator breaks and
you're in there with somebody and you're
like [ __ ] you got to stay there until it
gets fixed you know and that's how I
sometimes I that's just a fear I have
I'm not saying that's what marriage is
like but it's a fear that I have you
know it's just a fear of lack of you
know probably just having it just just
commit and be and just get through the
tough times and you know it's it's a
it's just a fear that I have you know
and also I think there's a fear of I
think every man probably has a fear of
not being able to you know finagle with
another woman or touch another woman's
crotch or you know just those sex
thoughts that come in come into your
brain you know touch some woman's you
know butthole or something down in like
a ruber somewhere in some fancy location
you know those are the things you have
in your head like in my head it's like
oh man I don't get married so you know
what if I run into some hot chick you
know over at the you know down in
Pensacola and she wants me to touch her
butthole for a second well the truth is
that's probably not gonna happen but
there's some weird thing inside of my
head or inside of men's head sometimes
that just it puts this weird outlier out
there in our thoughts and then we just
you know it's it's uneven you know and
then we don't act on the good
possibilities in front of us because we
have these weird things that we think
might happen that probably never will
and even if it does what the [ __ ] I'm
just touching someone's somebody's butt
in Florida for a minute and then what
then I'm lonely then I'm still sitting
out at the beach or trying to get it
uber or something I'm just back to being
lonely but those are something you know
there's some fears that I wrote what
else did I have
oh I fit what if I [ __ ] up you know in a
relationship or in a marriage and I
cheat or I stray
or I you know do porn I look at
pornography you know and that's part of
my marital you know agreement and so
that's scary to me because it's like you
know you make this Agreement you make
this commitment you want you know you
want to be able to honor it and you want
them not honor it you know so that's
these are just my fears I'm trying to go
through my fears oh sharing a bathroom
that's a fear I have about getting
married
did haven't shared a bathroom since
college bruh
honestly and that was hell you know that
was hell man
and I just that's my biggest fear it's
coming home and seeing some you know a
couple couple straight turds or
something in the toilet and they ain't
mine Anna's ship makes me scared bro you
know and that may seem crazy but that
[ __ ] makes me scared dude
I don't want to see somebody else's
straight-up turds and I don't want
somebody to see my turds you know I
don't know that sounds crazy brother it
might sound stupid but I just it makes
me scared man I see somebody else's
turds bro I might be out sayonara dude
and I know that's something wrong with
me I know it's not you know something's
[ __ ] wrong with me but I'm just
saying these are some out just weird
fears that I have and then I think one
of my biggest fears is probably just
that you know that I don't want to
create probably the same you know like
create a childhood for a child that's
similar to my childhood you know that I
guess I would fear that I create like a
shitty childhood for a kid and I think
that maybe that's sometimes I can't
access that fear as much but I
definitely think about that
I definitely think about that as being
you know probably something inside of me
that you know probably scares me a lot
and now some shitty childhood is good
you know I think I just want to I
wouldn't want to create a childhood
where kid feels unloved
because shitty look I don't care if that
kid you know if he's got two tank tops
and a winter Sun gang gang bro it's how
you're living you know
he may give Whedon macaroni 361 Daisy
here boy
then that's what we that's okay I don't
care if we have a you know this struggle
but I don't want you know just to [ __ ]
up somehow and create an environment
where a kid feels unloved so I think
that those are some of my fears now some
of my excitements I was thinking bout
this some of my excitements when it
comes to you know marriage and
relationship would be coming home and
having a loving family in the house you
know and coming home and having like a
loving family you know that I'm welcome
to be a part of you know and it's not
like you come in and you start hugging
people and people like who the [ __ ] are
you you know like you're somebody that
broke into somebody's house it's like a
family that your own family and they
care about you and everything and you're
allowed to come inside him and love them
so that's uh that's some excitement also
I was talking to some friends about this
this week you know and I was and one of
my buddies was saying you know don't
future trip you know try not to future
trip cuz sometimes when I think about
those sorts of things I put off you know
I stack everything into the equation
like okay you know I got you know like
if I you know first uh you know I get
married and then it's net you know like
then I start thinking well what if you
know now I got a family now I got a
house and you know what if there's a
divorce and what if there's and next
thing you know I'm it's forty years
later and I'm out on like a catamaran
living in a [ __ ] you know marina or
something cuz it's all I got left cuz
all my money's with the wife and the
children you know and and and then it's
just as crazy so you know I'm out there
looking for you know maybe research and
looking for treasure and this stupid
[ __ ] you know buying metal detectors and
stuff and the truth is that you know
none that not even the first thing has
happened but already I've taken myself
out of a you know possibly doing
something because I'm future tripping so
much and that's something that's gonna
you know that that I noticed and hum
that I'll do and another another thing
about uh
another thing I was thinking about is uh
and another thing I was singing about is
when it comes to finding somebody is
just you know try not to be too picky
you know I start to notice that my
friends we have so much access and
everything to you know to other people
and and so much you know and we have
access to other people and you see so
many other people and how other people
look and everything with so much
advertisement in in magazines and videos
and everything you're more likely to
compare kind of what's in front of you
to all these other sensationalized and
heightened things and we just gotta you
know I know that I know that I got to be
careful about that kind of stuff because
the truth is if that I'm judging
somebody on you know something little
you don't trust me I know I'm showing up
with nine little things nobody got more
little things wrong with them than me so
those are some things I guess that I've
been thinking about when it comes to
like you know marriages and
relationships thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz it's
alarming